Johnny Cash performs his first
number-one hit I walked a line on his
network TV show it's just one of his
more than a dozen chart-topping songs
cash died in 2003 but newly discovered
poetry from the legendary musician was
used to create a new album that's out
today some popular artists helped cash
his songs find a voice Anthony Mason
visited Cash's son outside Nashville
Tennessee to hear the collaborations
Anthony you lucky dog it's hard work got
to do it
we met John Carter Cash who's also a
producer of this album at the Tennessee
cabin his father converted into a studio
which is where most of the artists also
came to record this very special tribute
he built the catch cabin here with just
as a place to just to rest and relax
Johnny Cash's cabin is nestled at the
back of the family property in
Hendersonville Tennessee so this was
kind of a refuge for your family and
your dad my father called this property
Cedar Hill refuge in his last years
Johnny Cash built a studio inside and is
here that John Carter Cash has put some
of his father's poems to music with help
from artists like Brad Paisley
[Music]
and Kacey Musgraves and her husband
Rustin Kelly and Johnny's daughter
rosanne Cash
[Music]
what made you want him to put his poetry
to music oh the words called out on on
the page they just begged out really to
me to be heard Johnny Cash wrote
constantly letters lyrics poetry the
family found hundreds of pages after his
death was struck by the fact that he he
kept all this well yeah I mean he was a
he was a pack rat
my father was but you know I mean words
words meant the world to my dad I mean
if you look at that 200 pieces by any
artist that are cast aside you're gonna
find some gems within those and and and
that's what these are after publishing
forever words the unknown poems in 2016
can you give us a sample
certainly cash began looking for musical
collaborators
how did you feel to be asked oh I was
thrilled to be asked I was hoping I'd be
asked yeah because I heard about the
project
country artist alison krauss who's won
27 Grammys worked with songwriter robert
lee Castleman to finish Cash's the
captain's daughter it's like i want to
say holy ground but it is you do you're
like you really want to do it but you
really don't because you're afraid
there's a responsibility that comes
Oh huge one and and and the biggest one
is to be honorable cash also reached out
to Chris Cornell before his tragic death
last May he told me then you know that
dad was one of his greatest influences
[Music]
Johnny had recorded Cornell's song rusty
cage in 1996
[Music]
the Soundgarden front man picked Cash's
you never knew my mind my father wrote
you never knew my mind in 1967 when he
was going through a breakup with his
first wife Vivian and and Kris also
connected intimately with his own
experience to finish the song that my
father had started it would be one of
Cornell's last recording never really
knew
the song span Johnny Cash's life from
his teenage years - just before his
death in 2003 when he was mourning the
recent loss of his wife June my father
was persistent man he you know people
say did did your dad die of a broken
heart I know he died with one but I
don't think it killed him I think he'd
still be making music with us today you
know if his body hadn't given up the
song forever comes from one of the last
poems Johnny Cash wrote performed by his
old friends Kris Kristofferson and
Willie Nelson but the trees that I
planted still young
as songs I say still be sung
some really powerful stuff on this
record including their salsa songs by
Elvis Costello Jul John Mellencamp you
can imagine what it must be like as an
artist to be to be you know presented
with a Johnny Cash Lee reaction yeah
what you want to do it but you're
terrified you know it's like you you
have to honor it up yeah I want to hear
it all that's nice beautiful Anthony
mm-hmm
love that leather jacket it gets around
and you can hear more of CBS this
morning on our podcast on iTunes and
Apple's podcast that up and up next
we'll look at all that matter this week
you're watching the CBS this morning